[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon
good to go chin welcome kids it is
Monday morning January 30th February
coming in hot how fast this month go by
pretty fast kiddos pretty freaking fast
it is a cold rainy day here in Los
Angeles California thank you for tuning
in how are my fish doing good I'm glad
you asked we got another flower horn I
can't stop buying flower horns it's the
real problem because not supposed to mix
them because they kill each other but uh
uh I have seen some quite a few YouTube
videos of people mixing flower horns
with other fish which I've done that
successfully the biggest thing is uh
they're juvenile so there's two juvenile
flower horns and one big big ass uh
flowerhorn the biggest flowerhorn you've
ever seen because they're juveniles
right now it works but once they grow up
you have to get different tanks Jen you
know this dude you know all this stuff
man uh coming Fresh Off not much going
on in the fight world as far as fights
this past weekend but uh you get some
NFL playoffs and uh the Chiefs uh the
Chiefs and the referees versus the
Cincinnati Bengals was a fun game so
that was cool and then you had uh the
Philadelphia Eagles versus the fourth
string San Francisco 49ers that game
sucked I don't have a dog in the fight
I'm from Denver so I'm a Broncos fan
worked terrible so I have not one to
talk here
um Broncos fan charges Rams fan because
I'm here in Los Angeles now I've been
here for a hot second so my team was the
Niners going into this but without their
starting quarterback they're but they
all the quarterbacks got hurt they were
about to have freaking Chris McCaffrey
play quarter he was their fifth string
quarterback they're on their fourth
string Josh Johnson's their fourth
string quarterback Nick Bosa got hurt
early that dime piece who I love I want
to drink his sock juice
um it's just
I mean Philly's damn good they're good
they're good I'm excited to see what
happens in the Super Bowl uh it's going
for uh Cincinnati I always go for the
dogs but what can you do Super Bowl be
good either way man Super Bowl will be
and when is the Super Bowl was it
February oh the day after the fighting
plan on the 11th we're doing a original
OG fight campaign with Joe Rogan
February 11th with the original crew
Brian Callan Eddie Bravo Rogan and
myself that's on Rogan's platform not
mine so make sure you tune into that the
day before the Super Bowl so get you
some and we're doing a very special food
truck out there as well in case they're
flying down to Austin next week to get
some work done
so I'll announce who the guest is once
we get closer
um
but outside outside NFL football you uh
a lot of fight news not too many fights
you got a lot of fight news Conor in the
news Dana in the news
um you had some big fight announcements
what do you got for me chin fights this
weekend I mean
Bell tore has the most well-known
matchup going on between Ryan Bader and
Fedor
um that Johnny eblin Johnny eblin uh top
five middleweight regardless of
organization he's a straight Savage uh
fighting a tough Russian character now
this dude is from uh fedor's Team so
he's gonna he's gonna be a handful
and you look at his record Jen what is
he 30 31 and two
okay so 1781 knockout 31 and two dude
wow kid's a problem
he's been around for a hot second The
Horizon
um Bellator M1 he's done it all
ACB
a lot of M1 a lot of just Russian yes
pancreation
I'm fine for a hot second because he
made a tough night for him either way
though
um but still you got uh Neiman Gracie
fighting Lorenz Larkin Henry Corrales
definitely a better card than UFC Bel
tour is beating the UFC this weekend
their prelims says YouTube or Pluto TV
Pluto's tough right I don't know I never
used it yeah that's why it's tough you
never heard of it right I'm on the road
so sometimes when you get airbnbs that
have Pluto I guess I'll watch Fear
Factor or wiling out you know it's like
random [__] on there
yeah Pluto stuff Bellator
I'm surprised uh the prelims are are
they I'm surprised the prelims aren't
Showtime
there's still a Showtime entity
CBS program Plus I'll watch that one
that's on Saturday or Friday it says
February 4th so it should be Saturday
Saturday so I'll be watching The Green
Room from Springfield Missouri right
outside those Arts right outside I mean
an hour away apparently uh in
Springfield Missouri they're the home of
the biggest Bass Pro
uh shop like the original one it's the
biggest you've ever seen they also have
the biggest I heard of the biggest one
yeah apparently that's it dude you're
gonna love their fish tanks have you
seen them no
they're incredible uh the apparently
they have the biggest like aquarium yeah
oh my God they're incredible how much
fish stuff do you need though you know
what I'm saying for that big of a store
they sell like RVS and [__] in there and
like tanks
and your kids will love them if your
kids ever showed up there but they're
incredible
I mean how much is a sturgeon Bass Pro
Shop have oh my God stretchen is like
the biggest freshwater fish I remember
growing up in Denver Colorado my dad
used to take just a shout out to guard
Sporting Goods they got bought out by I
don't know dicks I think way to go dick
come on guard keep the fight dude but
guard sporting goods and people are
allowed to fish inside there
they're literally like that thing and
they're just fish in there try the [__]
out on the spot
yeah there it is
Springfield Missouri look at that group
or not
14 you probably didn't know what yeah
there it is
the wonders of wildlife Bass Pro Shops
I mean Bass Pro Shops they're crush it
that's it I don't know that's that's a
museum I'm not sure if it's the same
place but this is dope too
that's nuts yeah it goes over and around
no to be at that in your house it'll be
sick what's in Springfield so check it
out uh people have been uh tagging us
don't screw that Aquarium
different level the filtration system I
came in I don't know I don't know how
you do it I'm struggling with my three
tanks it's it's a beast
yeah I think people go in there like
divers and then clean stuff too oh yeah
oh yeah they yeah Deuce Bigalow style
yeah go in there and freaking
damn I'm excited for that yep
I am excited for that but the point is
I'll be watching Bellator on Saturday
night I'll have uh UFC one I'll have on
they'll have on you got Derek Lewis
Spivak
uh the biggest Korean in the UFC
downtown
Devin Clark down June just got starched
by my boy Jacoby uh but good for him
jumping back in there got tibera Ivanov
both thick thick heavyweights like very
squarish heavyweights and then you got
your boy the screen super Queen Super
Bowl turn this card's First Team all
Korean dude yep because originally was
supposed to be if you remember it's
supposed to be the Korean zombies card
in Korea right and Korean zombie got
hurt because shoulder still yep and they
changed everything around yeah there's a
reason why there's so many everyone's
like why so many Koreans on this random
card in the UFC Apex because remember
it's supposed to be a heavy Korean card
because it's going to take place in
Korea yeah now imagine a Korean fighter
and plan on fighting your backyard and
they go real quick change of plans you
get a fly to Vegas
so there's a lot of Korean names on
there Park Jung young Kim Jong-un Choi
Singh yuk uh Japanese guy
uh lee Jong-un
and there's just a bunch of different
names on there bad not bad Jesus Santos
Aguilar well I'm getting better aren't I
yeah
tough years years in the paint years
Mary went to Australia I thought
everyone was Chinese yeah but you were
so offended you learned super fast that
okay this is Chinese well what you
pointed out I was I felt stupid you know
I'm just not cultured like that I don't
know
oh [__] now it's too easy to do yeah it
was kind of cool to be like Chinese are
oh Korean right Japanese is cool the
difference like yeah dude it's like
but yeah so I'll be having the Bell Tour
card on probably and then tuning into
the UFC fights but there's been a lot of
news a lot of headlines in this crazy
Real Housewives MMA
show that we're in so let's see what we
got you
first one uh it's pretty
like probably the biggest one is like
allegations against Conor McGregor
the story I saw different articles about
him attacking a woman on his boat in
Ibiza in July I think it was the first
birthday celebration like a boat party
yeah sorry not both yacht yeah party yes
and then apparently she knew this woman
through the neighborhood and then
invited her onto the boat
and everything was fine the next morning
she claims that he
kicked her in the stomach punched her in
the face or in the chin and then told
her he's going to drown her and then she
got so scared that she jumped off the
yacht
so it's her only
kind of Saving Grace was Jesus or jump
into the ocean which sounds insane but
yeah that's how scared she was yeah and
then she was ready according to this you
know I wait till I hear everything who
knows these are allegations who knows
the problem with all this is there's a
common theme with Connor right it's like
remember when he beat up like that DJ's
girl remember the DJ the DJ like he's
cool with everyone and then like
midnight strikes he turns into this
Dublin werewolf like as soon as 1201 get
dude party's over and he freaks out like
he has this Jekyll and Hyde kind of
personality I don't know what's going on
there if that's drugs if that's you know
CT she's lying or not lying I don't know
she also said that or she also mentioned
that she didn't identify Conor in the
beginning but later on she did identify
she said of someone in his party but
then later on she said it was Conor and
then the case was closed and it got
reopened again because of the new
investigation so who knows what's going
to go on
um let's see
uh McGregor saw he got aggressive with
his former neighborhood friend after
pirate all night as the sun came up
telling you dude you don't want to be
around Conor McGregor when the sun comes
out that's I mean these are this is
science all of his behavior change and
once the sun came up and he became out
of that and he became very aggressive he
insulted her parents and then kicked her
in the stomach with your teeth kick are
we talking about like the straight up
Shin to gut
punched her on her chin
after she fell he jumped on a report he
declared I'm going to drown you who do
you think you are did she do anything it
doesn't say what she the woman was so
scared she jumped off the yacht under
the water Escape how far out were they
do where she was rescued shortly by the
red crossbow initially she identified
McGregor as an attacker to our Rescuers
but later reported told uh Guardia Silva
agents it wasn't him and that she just
wanted to go home oh interesting that
led to the guardian of positive
investigation and since we were open
after the victim filed a report against
Conor in Ireland as you hear what
happened to her car yeah it burned it
set on fire yeah
yeah it's just it's getting old isn't it
with Conor it's like come on dude get
your [__] together you guys know me I'm
a big Connor dick rider but enough is
enough
in the UFC just like the Matrix just
dodging [__] like hey whoa tough Conor
well Ferguson Dana stops is what fight
clap League whoa whoa whoa like they're
just they're the bad boys of
professional sports man
and which it just shows you how powerful
the UFC is not one single Advertiser
sponsor in the UFC has come out and said
anything or dropped out that's that's
yeah gangster yeah super gangster that's
how powerful the UFC is
or just these people are involved these
companies like yeah so you'll see yeah
yeah it's human [__] fighting we saw we
know we signed up for it's like whoa
this is in today's world that is dicey
yeah yep yep yeah I don't it doesn't
seem like anything comes from the stuff
you know kind of just keeps getting by I
mean well he's denying denying it
obviously so who knows what the actual
story is yeah it's tough because he's so
famous he's so big he's like crossed
over into this straight up celebrity
like Justin Bieber [__]
of course people can come after you and
your money and try and settle so who
know I don't know I need more
information all I know is I'm sick of
this stuff you know
kind of has a lot on his plate right now
man so if he's gonna do tough against uh
Tony Ferguson
if he's gonna do he has a movie coming
out I think it's on Amazon uh Prime The
Roadhouse movie so he sounds like he's a
obviously a busy busy cat man so he's
doing all this stuff
you know I don't know how many fights he
has left
who knows where his legs at he does The
Ultimate Fighter here's a question for
the gentleman in the room would uh would
you tune in to watch Connor's 21st on
Ultimate Fighter would that be the thing
that brings you back I would I'll
probably watch at least the first
episode because I'm just you know it's
exciting to see Conor McGregor you'd
watch everyone
yeah yeah I mean I'd watch it yeah I'd
watch it I mean if his first episode
sucked I'd probably drop off but who
knows
Tony Ferguson
that [__] too so it's like two you
basically booked two jokers to run the
ultimate fighter try and revamp this
thing it needs life yeah they get the
those clear King and that's what they're
trying to do with Tony and
um Conor here I I I think it would do
well it's still on ESPN plus so the
hardcore is definitely gonna find it the
casuals definitely won't it'll do but by
far the best tough ratings they've ever
had on ESPN but if it's starting to go
back to Heyday they need to put down
regular ESPN but they never would it's
get it's gonna be interesting to see
what they do
mm-hmm and if you're a Connor fan it's
the perfect fight for him you know this
is one of those fights so you can see
him winning
um that's not like you sign up to fight
a Dustin Poirier just engage here
makachev this is a fight it's a winnable
fight he should be slightly favored in
it you just don't know what version of
counter you're gonna get now before his
injury against poor he didn't look
terrible
and I assume Connor has enough respect
for himself he's not gonna sign for a
fight if he's not ready to go you know
so
if your Connor fans is the right choice
now if he beats Tony which will be
favored to do it's Off to the Races I
think you can get two fights out of
Conor left in his entire career outside
whatever gimmicks he does in boxing or
whatever but and then you'll see you're
gonna get Connor verse Tony Ferguson
then you get carnivorous marketev
then he's gonna do that Macho fight to
be tough you know price right off in the
sunset or do boxing that Nate Diaz
Trilogy is always there or you know
something like the Jake Paul stuff is
there but as far as UFC high level [__]
goes it's gonna be you got two fights
left in counter
um the slicky suits and shouts that
shouts the show had ever seen before on
top of silver and I coached my team to
Victory crazy some Journey I've just
been offered to coach this role again I
like it it's the full immersion which is
needed I see fires line up I know it's
ahead I've been ready mother truckers
hashtag Stay Ready that's from Connor so
he's actually like saying he would put
pot potato oh let's do it oh here's the
thing too it it gives it buys Connor
time right when you saw the test and all
that so he doesn't if you were like
where's the fight where's the fight
they'd have to do this weird loophole
where they have to give them exemptions
so this buys time we know at the end of
this show he's gonna fight it's a
perfect case scenario for the UFC this
is a no-brainer yeah and Tony Ferguson
it couldn't be a bigger
goose egg for him I mean the Tony
Ferguson business you know it's tough
lately this is a big opportunity for him
and this hey this ain't an easy fight
for Connor like Tony didn't look
terrible against Diaz and Chandler I
mean when we fought Chandler he was
actually doing well in the beginning
so I'm with it
Connor needs to win yes he does bad
yep oh yeah I kind of got hit by a car
scraped up his ass there's his ass right
here the boy in shape though
I saw I was reading like the top
comments I think uh funny or no I just
like they're just it looks like she's
you know thirsting oh yeah yeah yeah his
body right back
um
yeah just like a small path I probably
wasn't paying attention got a bang of a
car just got a bang of a car just from
behind
a sun trap the driver can't see me oh
full speed straight through me thank you
God it was in my time thank you
wrestling at Judo also having awareness
and Landing saved my life yeah and he
was pretty nice to the guy that hit him
oh I know I saw him he's like what's up
man it's okay it's okay
that's cool and then he drove him back
to uh his place well that guy's house
was set on fire today just kidding
um
yeah this is a video but it's like he's
on a road bike let me see Connor's bike
there
let's see if he focuses on it he's not
like it straight or kind of he got too
much money riding that bike Doug orbia I
got a better bike than that get a real
road bike man was he going to the store
for milk what he's not like doing road
work on that thing
it's so hard to understand what Connor
says a lot of times too though yeah I
enjoy it though
I'm so sorry
no I don't give a box they all go it's
all good yeah
sorry you guys are sorry
yeah
grab it and throw into this I'm gonna
actually need to live home they accept
that points
how many left homemade
foreign
bites on the road I see I don't I don't
mess with it oh I'm only on Trails I
trained my road bike to a gravel bike so
I can go on the dirt trails now it's
just too dangerous I love it nothing
better I love being on road bikes but
it's just so dangerous man yeah remember
Sean Bradley that seven footer what bike
he was on I have no clue he's paralyzed
now
ride his bike in Salt Lake City Utah got
hit all the time
I put her on road bike how you miss him
no clue
but you know distracted drivers all the
time so oh texting man yeah number one
problem for drivers
let's take a little break fan gotta keep
these house lights on and here at thick
boys Studios Springfield Missouri I will
see you this Friday and Saturday baby
I'll be checking out all your aquariums
uh the big bass pro shop whatever
everyone tells me to go there probably
gonna live in there probably gonna hide
out and sleep there that will be my
hotel but that is Springfield Missouri
this freaking Friday Saturday two shows
Friday two shows Saturday at the Blue
Room comedy club in Springfield Missouri
get your tickets out thickboy.com or
fatkz.com this episode of the shop show
is brought to you by the best freaking
energy for your brain of all time I'm
talking about my Limitless pill I'm
talking about that Kratom I'm talking
about happy hippo that's Happy hippo.com
go there if you've always want to try
Kratom you always want to see if it was
for you they offer in a variety of forms
you have pill chewables gummies powder I
use the concentrated shots I just took
one we threw it away I use the Cherry
shots or the pink lemonade they just
have butterscotch that just dropped as
well I take one of those for any show
that I do stand up Podcast whatever it
is your boys on Kratom I swear by it but
you can't just use any Kratom you got to
be able to trust what's actually in the
bottle or the pills and that's where
happy hippo comes into play go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick 23
thick with three C's t-h-i-c-c-c 23 you
twimps off the entire site for Life
share it with anybody you want your
friends your family your grandma your
grandpa your UPS guy I don't care you
guys get 20 off all things that have
happyhippo.com promo code thick23 now
let's get back to the program
Sonic you guys thought we're getting
right back nope we got one last one for
you have you always want to try the best
nootropic on the planet we talking about
that Alpha Brain they have Alpha Brain
Black that's a super concentrate Alpha
Brain if our brain just was in country
you want to step your game up check out
Alpha Brain Black Label that's right
it's the doers Alpha Brain the number
one nootropic on the planet over one
million bottles sold all right you can
pick it up right now at Walmart but you
can help your boy out go to audit.com
and you save 10 off the entire site the
entire site of on it maybe you start
late on your New Year's resolution
whatever it is let Anna help you out we
have supplements protein powders fish
oil creatine Warrior bars protein bites
nut butters for your mouth we got it all
we got training Gear streaming Fitness
you have no reason not to eat your thick
ass in shape but let on it help you the
best products the best supplements on
planet Earth if you want to fire up that
brand of yours get you some it'll be
Stephen Hawkins in your next meeting go
ahead get some the best nootropic on the
planet talking about Alpha Brain I like
the Alpha Brain Black all right go to
audit.com you save temp shop the entire
site off every product I just told you
about streaming Fitness kettlebell
kettlebells uh steel Club Macy's battle
ropes dope on it workout tees shorts
joggers they got it all anything you
need also Alpha Brain we got it all
audit.com shop temps off the entire site
you're welcome for reals Springfield
Missouri see this Friday and Saturday
but let's get back to the program
all right this is probably one of the
bigger news over the weekend was Dana
White's announcement of UFC 287 and then
I'll show you the card right here what I
tell you when when John annik was on I
said the UFC it's been such a dark hole
man I guarantee you start seeing big
fights rolling out because that'll take
the distraction away from all this dark
[__] we're seeing you know on TMZ all
this stuff if they want to get past that
and get fans more excited I guarantee
the UFC start getting big name fights
and what happened two days after that
the food truck came with John Annex you
get Jon Jones fight zero gone now you
have Alex Pierre Izzy Gilbert Burns
Jorge masvidol you get all these big boy
fights just rolling out rolling out
yeah I know
uh just say yeah according so I heard
it's supposed to take place in Brooklyn
with the New York Commission
that's kind of Experia is he is he
slightly favoring that which he should
be Izzy's promo was Savage too yeah
Savage better than Burns Cory miles a
fun one
I'm just curious about welterweight
what's this mean for a Bilal Mohammed
what's this mean for hamzat
does that mean hamzat Muhammad
how is that supposed to be stuck in
middleweight now though I don't know
yeah but that's what I don't think UFC
trusts will make 170 but
I I don't know what's going on so I
figured if homside goes up to
middleweight they would give him Pierre
for a title shot but Izzy's like now I'm
down to do it so he's gonna jump up
there go the middleweight rankings who
would he get at middleweight
who didn't give him a middleweight
Robert Whittaker you don't have a dance
partner right mm-hmm
because when he was supposed to fight uh
Paulo Costa and Costa's having some
issues right the financial stuff yeah
contract contract but then they they put
somebody else in there for Robert
Whitaker versus now on that uh car next
weekend
next weekend yeah I'm doing like
campaign for it because you have Alex
wilkinowski and Mark Chev and then
remember we're supposed to be Whitaker
and Paulo Costa Costa was like this is
fake news I haven't agreed to contract
he's trying to get out of his contract
foreign
who do they pair them up with this one
here yeah yep this next Saturday
you have Yaya Rodriguez Josh Emmett
no boy Tyson page was fighting type in
Robert Whittaker who did Hook's opponent
yeah I thought they
I don't know I heard that he was
supposed to fight Alex but hey but now
that this matchup came the rematch he's
not doing it so I'm not sure
so there's nothing
hmm
that's a bummer
I'd love to see uh Robert Whittaker Alex
be her fight
yes he was supposed to be Alex I think
but Izzy took the fight so interesting
yeah I'll experience much better matchup
for Robert Whittaker than is he
oh you could do hamzat Whitaker Robert
Whittaker hamzat who wouldn't want that
yeah that'd be insane super talented not
so crazy
I mean probably the toughest matchup for
hamzat
go that quick I'm striking and can
wrestle
explosive
UFC has to figure out what they want to
do with onset they can't get them a
fight at welterweight yeah and we say
that wilted weight you'd have to go
Muhammad
that'd be a great fight too and Muhammad
did call him out although
because because Gilbert Burns called out
Colby Covington right after he won but
obviously Kobe's not fighting that
Maslow has a fight so you you could do
you can still do Kobe Vs homdot that'd
be a dope ass fight too or Muhammad Kobe
off all great if Tom's out jumps the
middleweight into Muhammad uh Colby and
then you can do hamzat Robert Whittaker
great fights
depend on what DLC wants to do you do
hamzat versus uh Cannon air
yeah I'd rather watch tough fight for
Kansas yeah top five I don't know why
Canada is just like but but you you if
you if I'm that can there is a big boy
too so if Hamza jumps in they already is
number three middleweight in the world
and then you can jump him to Robert
Whittaker
Robert Whittaker homes that's the fight
though
I bet we announcement of Hamza in the
next month
yeah hopefully he's super exciting
uh your boy Luke rockhold I guess he
asked for his release from the UFC and
they did release him
so he said remember he was kind of
teasing a comeback yeah he's sort of
retired yeah so yeah in this article it
says like uh this is Animania UFC
released in and they released him so he
can take care of Jake Paul that's what
Luke is saying yeah I'm not buying that
I love Luke yes no this is my boy he's
been on fight campaigns all that stuff
food truck and
love Luke but I highly doubt the UC was
like we're gonna let you go to hunt down
Jake Paul and then with someone like but
you're way big it's like shut up
your dad makes sense he's so much he's
so much bigger than Jake he's a big dude
Logan yeah that makes sense
I can't imagine Jake or Logan taking
this fight
especially Jake Jake that makes sense
nor would Jake make that fight happen
you see Jake has Mike Perry as the
backup in case Tommy Fury pulls out
foreign
Jake and Tommy's interesting yeah
talking like drew a dick on Jake's
Channel well what is this fifth grade
and by the way that is the fight with uh
Tommy Fury is now confirmed finalized in
Saudi Arabia in February yep February
26th
February 26 I wonder if I'm on the road
for that we could do a fight you're
paying for that too
because we have one in
23rd so maybe not oh I can't do it
because yeah the 23rd is Bakersfield one
night when one show only breaks field
almost sold out with the 26 I'm around
yeah that'd be fun they could be good
because the fight campaign uh next
Saturday for the UC Australia cards on
Rogan's platform so that'll check the
box for us for the month of February
and we have one March 4th too for the
Jon Jones fight will you do it see who's
in town
interesting
that's dope though
and I don't know if we can show this but
either way we don't have to show this
this is basically when Tommy Fury and
Jake Paul uh did their comfort you know
their what do you call it Face-Off and
then apparently Tommy Fury slapped Jake
Paul but I didn't see any angles play it
from happening
oh
oops this is in the UK
why is Jake's hair like that I think it
looks dope it's just crazy
damn I thought I thought uh I thought
Tommy Fury was big the time their head
sizes are so different huh so apparently
slapped him right there he kind of
pushed him
yeah
you better hope Fury's Dad don't get
involved
boy I think Tommy fear is so [__] for
some reason I thought he was a bigger
bigger than Jake too really I thought
that would be his Saving Grace he's
[__] yeah I bet you Jake knocks him
out on a four
you want to hear him here sure handsome
bastard
distractingly good looking he's
definitely good looking yeah oh my God
[Music]
you already know it you're gonna crack
Under Pressure you're not Built For This
Moment you're not Built For This Moment
you're an imposter it's all a Bravado
it's all fake confidence
you can't even knock out a taxi driver
all right all right all right let's keep
it going
I was beating bad people than you when I
was 14 damages that's not true look at
your pro boxing record a lot of pressure
on Tommy Fury man
and then Jake did give like he goes I
love you know Tyson Fury but I gotta I
gotta do this yeah brother yeah Tyson
fear is just having a ball there Tyson's
the best
and yeah so thank
you you mentioned earlier but thank
goodness Mike Perry is a backup because
that's also such a fun fight too oh yeah
yeah
I think I think my pair gives them a
tougher challenge
I'm just not sold on Tommy yeah neither
am I I'm not I'm not on Dave uh
portnoy's Vibe with Rogan he's like he's
not a real boxer like he's a boxer he's
still a boxer but
you know the only reason we're talking
about him because he's Tommy Fury uh
Tyson Fury's brother and his record
where he was like I was beating guys up
better than you have four teams like bro
your professional record is the worst
I've ever seen as far as strength of
scheduled it
it's the worst remember that one guy's
like three and 200 or whatever yeah
classic
I mean he got big obviously because his
brother who's the best boxer ever do in
the heavyweight division then also from
uh love Island he's my favorite
character on there dude him his Girl
Molly may still together wow hell yeah
good for uh Mike Perry though yeah
so either way I'm at least but don't
have Mike pages to back up if I like at
least give him a fight so he can train
for it and then you know have a fight oh
that'd be cool too that's what they
should do is um schedule a fight and
then that guy just hey if something
happens you're not fighting my periods
yeah that would be cool no idea who
would that be at least he's open to
fight Mike Perry
but Mike Perry's a tougher fighting
Tommy Fury for all you real boxing dude
he did work on Michael Venom page which
is crazy yeah it's so crazy he's just a
dog yeah
uh this is a real quick one so Floyd
mayweight Floyd Mayweather Jr is going
to do an exhibition fight with Aaron
Chalmers who is like a big star a
reality star
in uh the UK I don't get it Geordie
Shore yeah I mean I guess he just you
know collect the money
first this guy but this guy's actually a
legit fighter though he's fought in
Bellator I think
yeah he did
maybe he's still with belter he's five
and two
um yeah I mean good for this kid
um Aaron Chalmers for getting this good
good for him man no no hate on him it
just it used to be something special
right like yo you're fighting Floyd May
like when Logan Paul did it or really
when Connor did like holy [__] now it's
like how many people are gonna say they
got to fight the great Floyd Mayweather
yeah you know that's like it's slowly
being it's not as exciting anymore no no
he fought like a sparring partner the
other day you know
like how bored are you or is it a money
thing I'm so curious like why he does it
I don't know if he talks about it if
he's just like it's easy money man it's
like sparring for me it's kind of gives
me something to do I get that in that
regard I get it and he's given you know
this guy a chance so good for him
uh here's some a couple of fight
announcements which are pretty cool song
ya dong that killer he's gonna be
fighting Ricky Simone in April great
[__] second hell yeah
phenomenal fight
and then we have Edson Barboza who's
been his streak has been pretty crazy
right now but Essen Barboza fighting
that up-and-common building quarantino
so Billy Currington is a Savage yeah
this is edson's record right now which
is one two three four five six seven
he's lost five out of seven yeah and
this is Billy's
Billy's he is 17 and four but uh he's
doing two
last four
Billy should beat him we're rooting for
Billy here and also we're rooting for
Edson remember him and his son so nice
yeah
um let's see oh there's a quick one from
Frank this is their Fight League
you guys talked about it before right
and the one that they're doing with like
Rampage and I think Tito and everything
else so they're gonna give I'll play for
you he's doing something that no one
else has done before we're giving a
piece of
that you're going to have health
insurance life insurance make sure you
guys join and take advantage
so that's what we're doing for their
Fighters a piece of the pie
health insurance and life insurance
insane it's talks you just hopefully in
a grand scale that they they're in
business for a while you know yeah
there's a reason why it's tough to do
this UFC in these you know you think
about like what Affliction did with
these crazy paydays and pride and stuff
like it you know I'm curious about the
business model I hope it works out
yeah anything Frank's involved in you
know I love I love frank and it's cool
that they're actually trying to offer
this at least that's cool you gotta see
if it's sustainable because let's say if
they're out of business in two years
that sucks yeah then every other
promoter's bike why would we offer stuff
that they did clearly doesn't work so
they're they're
fight is going to be not go doing what
Bellator did back in the day where it's
like you know Royce Gracie versus Ken
Shamrock Seven or one of the [__] you
know so it's like yeah Frank and pull
people Tito can pull people chill can
pull people Rampage can pull people but
in order to be a sustainable Fight
League you have to base base it off your
Youth and the prospects so you gotta
invest in those prospects now they do
have Frank mayor's daughter who's the
biggest female Prospect in I don't know
she's our LeBron James a female fighting
she's a Savage so if she's the face the
company you know like you think Kyla
Harrison's dominant this little girl is
a Savage dude yeah so she what's up
she did yeah but with UFC yep so she's
going to be an ambassador and I didn't
know what the hell nil meant but then I
had to look it up but so she's like the
first ever nil for the UFC which means
name images to represent the FC
brilliant for the UFC because she's
clearly she's not right for the UFC she
shouldn't be a new city she's young
she's at University of Iowa wrestling
she's a freshman there she's Savage and
then she's in she's gonna probably
fighting up to her dad's League
which she'll get experience there but
while she's doing it the UFC owns all
her likeness and imaging
which is tough if you're was it what's
what's the fightly called Frank involved
in United Fight League UFL if you're UFL
and the UFC owns all her name likeness
and she's your biggest star
what limitations are there so if the
UFC's promoting or which is going to
promote the UFL but if they own all her
rights and likeness and your Skinner
fights like you're a feeder league but
then really the UFC's gaining all the
benefit from it yeah I don't know how it
works but yeah but good for her yeah
she's such a young good for UFL I'm
telling you guys killer
Savage yeah her her whole family brother
Savages and football like she's a
problem
she's cornered her dad in huge fights
like she's been around the game has you
know Frank Mayer's skill set but with
her mom's tenacity you got problems
yeah she she's you know the close thing
we have as far as females go to the you
know when you saw the LeBron out of high
school or Carmelo Anthony in high school
she's in that stage now she's doing
College a freshman at University of Iowa
wrestling ever heard of it you know
she's a Powerhouse college wrestling
it's it's exciting man
shout out to the UFL
and Frank's a smart guy too so
yeah and Harrison who's the The
Mastermind behind all of it too so we'll
see Mark it to you but you got it they
they gotta they gotta do a not even a
balance if it's a scale it should be
like this you can't have your old like
Frank don't get me wrong I love these
guys but I'll we have Rampage coming up
on food truck so I'll talk to him about
it we can't have Frank Rampage chale
hoist like that old model you can't Bank
it off that we you need to get the
public excite about you know uh Frank
mayor's daughter and these other young
prospects I don't know who else they
have but you the majority of your
business has to be that not this with
these old heads there's no longevity
there there's not
then when it comes to the fighter I'd
love to talk to them about this when it
comes to fighter compensation as far as
insurance and life insurance
so if let's say hoist Gracie or say
Coleman sign up took one fight the
health care for the rest of their life
you know if Bigfoot Silva takes one
fight you guys covering his bills for
the rest of his life even though the
majority of his career was in the UFC
and elsewhere
if no girl signs up big nog you're
taking care of him even though all his
damage and injuries came from prior
organizations you're covering all that
like what's the limitations on all that
hope it's like yeah it's time with us we
take care of everything that'd be great
for the fighters great
yeah let's hope it works knock on wood
uh this is Jose Aldo we announced I
think last week that he's going to be
boxing and uh yeah because they did the
announcement of the UFC in Brazil right
and then they were like then there was a
commercial for his boxing I don't even
see the commercial totally forgot that
yeah the commercial for his like big
announcer retired but also fighting
February 10th that's pretty cool that
they did that thing yeah crazy uh and
it's a crazy Jose Aldo got in the Hall
of Fame before
Anderson Silva
not weird
that was a little weird I mean he's
gonna I don't know we'll see
but um Whatchamacallit so they finally
announced his opponent and it's someone
named Emmanuel Zambrano and apparently
his opponent is not that great
33 year old opponent zero and two
and it's not competed in over two years
okay but that's kind of how you're
supposed to do it though right box and
that's how you're supposed to do it yeah
that's how you do it when you're a young
Prospect right you feel it out but I
mean he's obviously a prospect not Young
big name
yep alrighty
let's jump to
all right this one's another quick one I
don't I never even heard of this guy but
his name is Joseph Holmes and he has a
nickname like ugly something
let me look here
Susie's saying happened last night we're
here at the xko fighting this is Kevin
Holland talking here okay and then he
apparently his name is ugly man Joe the
guy that that's accusing Kevin Holland
and his boys of jumping him okay so that
this Regional fight promotion enjoying
ourselves and we're on our way out
Holland explained in a since deleted
Instagram video of course I see ugly man
Joe not going to deny that he's walking
up the stairs I was walking down the
stairs he didn't want to walk on the
other side of the stairs where the guy
he was beefing was he didn't want to he
didn't want to walk on the other side of
the stairs where the guy he was beefing
was so he walked on my side of the
stairs like I was gonna move I was like
bro chill out as soon as I put my hand
up to say chill you grabbed me as soon
as he grabbed me we kind of almost went
flying down the stairs quick reactions
neither one of us fell over by the time
I got to fix my code I didn't know what
happened I don't remember any of the
stuff he was talks about all I remember
is him getting into a fight with and me
breaking it up sounds good that's the
part of the story that sticks all the
other stuff is drama that you have and
that's between you and another man don't
you find name for clout don't put me in
your BS yeah so that guy's claiming that
Kevin Holland and his boys jumped him
and apparently the beef comes from Kevin
Holland knowing the guy the guy dated
Kevin Hound's uncle's ex-girlfriend or
something like that it's like super
Street kind of stuff you know but I
don't know if that's really true
Holland wasn't done yet offering homes
20 000 to spar because you'll see like
likely won't mess him up you're right
about that he went to fight me we got
gyms you said to tell you if he sent a
contract I doubt UFC will send you a
contract if you want to spar you can
Spar me up my gym my little brother hit
you up online he's a miner you shared
him on your page calling me clown so of
course I'm gonna tag you and stuff like
that
saying if you want to come to my gym and
Spark for 20 grand I'll give you a
chance to spark 20 grand here I'm offer
you 20 grand inspired me said Spar three
times in a row
yeah go sparm dude 20 grand
is it 20 grand Win Lose or Draw
it's I mean from 620 come on down it
sounds like he's just paying him just to
spar him but maybe just whoever wins
yeah
I don't know it it's just like whatever
Real Housewives of the UFC
and here's a couple of tattoos back
tattoos this is Charles Olivera
has a brand new back tattoo of a lion
damn that's dope yeah it's a huge one
really dope tattoo
and then your boy chitovera
Cheeto got another one from cartoon from
cartoon well it's the same one but
finally it's finished
the back tattoo damn that is filthy and
then you know like cartoon I think he
charges
[__] so crazy like 50 Grand foreign
with them yep
so who does most of uh Travis Barker
stuff I mean cartoon does all the big
boys yep
all righty and then that guy looks like
Cheeto in 30 years right very similar if
it's if Cheetos head gets yeah yeah well
when you get older your head gets better
yeah
uh back to the fights so in Ghana
revealed that he could be fighting Tyson
Fury so it's you know you mentioned
before it's most likely going to be
Tyson Fury yeah he wouldn't listen I
love that he's banking himself and like
UFC did this did that he's not walking
away from that big boy UFC money and he
did offer him big money regardless you
know re in regulations to the pay that
Fury or Anthony Joshua Wilder get yeah
it's not that but for the UFC that from
Big Boy money in the heavyweight
division to fight he walked away from
that not being like I'm just gonna you
know test the waters in free agency with
pfl or rides in a one Championship no no
he knows he's getting this Fury fight
you're not walking away from that type
of money unless you're gonna [__] you
money he knows for a fact he's in the
fury fight they have a verbal agreement
and also he does he does remember he was
asking for other things that didn't
involve money and the UFC just wouldn't
listen Dana did his best to make the UFC
or make Francis look bad France is best
to make the UFC look bad end of the day
just Francis had a bigger fish out there
and that's Tyson Fury yeah the Gypsy
fighting fish is Tyson Fury
but Francis I mean uh Tyson Fury does
have to fight usick in April that ain't
in these by far stuff's match up in for
[__] ever yeah
and so he would want him he'd want Fury
in June of July
which is kind of soon after April but
especially you just gotta hope that that
because that's not an easy fight for
Fury that's gonna be a dog fight usick
is a [__] Savage so even if you were
to win that fight which I'm bet on Fury
right but I'm fear fear is my favorite
athlean Combat Sports I'm bet on Fury
tough fight firm stylistically using
just just a [__] bona fide winner
even Fury to win that fight he's gonna
be beat up dude like that that's not a
fight you're gonna go into and just get
out you know scot-free so I'd be
surprised if they do it you know right
away but I bet you get Fury Francis this
year yeah that'd be pretty damn dope I
hope listen Francis isn't gonna beat him
but I hope it happens for Francis
because then he made the right choice
this doesn't come from where she made
the worst choice
hmm a lot of money though
hopefully
all right here's a little quick update
on Dana White's power slap I guess the
first time it came out the numbers were
really terrible the second time the
second week it actually did more but it
was coming off of the aw wrestling thing
and it says in this article that I guess
they had a million something people
watching the aw and like over half of
them dropped off to watch this power
supply over there yeah it's a tough sell
man I listen I enjoy a [__] show I feel
bad for those guys how much they're
paying then Dana went at some kid on
Instagram I have it here
or Twitter uh so this guy put road to
the title where you get 2K and 2K and
maybe 10K and 10K if you win it all Dana
responds this guy goes that's how MMA
started too box on cards make this kind
of money still educate yourself before
you open your Gap no no I I think
powerful juice box is educated the
problem is uh the road time we hit 2K
and 2K and Danny goes yeah that's how
MMA started too yeah [__] in 1993 2K
and 2K these slap fight dumbasses can
make more at Starbucks
that's how MMA started too yeah no no we
know you [__] over guys for a long
long time you just regurgitating your
same business model but you can't get
away with an MMA anymore so you're using
these poor idiots in the slap Fight
League and they're buying it needing it
up
whatever that we've gone over this
[__] slap Fight League so many times
my issue with it all is
Jiu Jitsu is an actual sport
you know how many eyeballs new eyeballs
you could bring to attention to a Gordon
Ryan or these monsters and Jitsu who are
legit athletes meant Savages and there's
real money in that sport 2K 2K you
kidding me Gordon Ryan laughs at that
imagine if Dana put all his efforts and
his promotional Powerhouse machine
behind it Gordon Ryan or Jiu Jitsu a
real sport that's going to grow UFC
imagine if he did that
like why waste all your resources on
this slap fight because he ended up
guaranteed [__] you in the future dude
guarantee it guarantee this does not end
well for Dana
guaranteed at least a Sci-Fi part for
sure no that's what I'm saying just slap
fight that's not gonna end well no the
lawsuits are going to come the CT down
the road I don't know if it's gonna be
this year but it's gonna be next year it
could be 10 years somebody's have an
issue
there's no positive to this thing in any
facet from the pay the conversation the
notoriety there's nothing the attention
it's bringing Dana after the altercation
with his wife none of it makes sense for
the life of me I've made some dumb ass
choices there's none Dumber in the
history of business than Dane in the
slap Fight League
dumbest Choice I've ever seen a smart
person make hands down
that reminds me uh Logan Paul mentioned
something because Logan Paul slap yeah I
had a slap thingy as well but
here we go
dude he was kicking ass in that uh he
was amazing dude crazy yeah so it says
major announcements tomorrow and then he
tags Dana White yeah here's your
announcement Prime's gonna be the
official drink of UFC or slap Fight
League oh okay that's all it is he's a
contract WWE he's not fighting the UFC
nor should he like that just I love
Logan that's a bad idea the the
announcement describes the official
drink of the UFC some [__] like that
so in his sometimes the hydration drink
because they have they have monster
right now but that's the energy drink
Primetime energy drink and we tried
Prime on Golden hour they sent they sent
it to us it's Kool-Aid it's low sugar
Kool-Aid it's fantastic yeah I didn't
have my kids drink it like [__] Kool-Aid
drink this Prime stuff and apparently in
the UK it's like flying off the shelves
people sound for like 400 a freaking
case like it's impossible to get America
not so much but this announcement it's
he's teasing that it's gonna be this big
fight thing it's just gonna be his prime
drink is involved in some capacity in
the UFC or slap Fight League that makes
more sense yeah yeah staying smart stays
relevant
foreign
by the way the packaging of those Prime
bottles are cool the colors I like them
the flavor's insane I mean you quench
the [__] on my thirst it's almost too
sugary tasting for me for a guy who grew
up addicted to Sugar because my teeth I
can't have sugar that's the best thing
is touch these lips in a hot second and
it was cold I had that whatever Cherry
whatever that [__] it's Kool-Aid dude
it's coconut water it's flavored coconut
water with less sugar
my kids are gonna be all over it
yeah it's doing pretty damn well this is
a little older but this came out after
we did our show last week so this is
Jamal Hill responding to Yuri prohaska's
call out Jamal Hills is funny it's yeah
for sure
the disrespect Jamal Hills get man
congratulations
I'm coming I feel like you didn't know
what to say
I feel like he didn't know he he was
just like I need to do something he's
like well you didn't tell he was
thinking he was all congratulations
where you at though
by the way
that's what she said
this is funny that was pretty damn dope
yeah
that's a good fight
oh yeah if it happens it happens who
knows I mean because it'll happen here
eventually yeah you're the Savage he's
young enough too
so Michael Venom page has been posting
about a lot of his old karate footage
didn't we show this last week this is a
different one oh [__] yeah so this is
him doing a spinning kick
what poor souls were signing up in this
karate Wagga yeah
[Music]
and just like
Adrian Yanez Michael venompage says uh
if you want to learn how to do it he has
his own only fans now too oh [__] yeah
people are jumping on the only fan stuff
I guess so
and not doing
poor gay stuff yeah yeah and this is a
update on Sage Northcutt you know he's
fighting him boy yeah he's fighting one
I think the ones first ever in the
United States do you ever think he lays
in bed like God I should just got my
engineering degree at Texas A M
I know he was on a great path but I mean
still we like oh we love him this is
such a nice kid if his passion his
passion is really Tim Tebow of MMA his
passion is martial arts so yeah yeah
um all right so here's a little bit of
him uh sparring back or hitting the bag
yeah
he's going hard on the paint on this
[__] thing
God damn yeah super fast we see all
Jesus is saved or whatever but um his
whole thing isn't a talent issue it's a
experiences [__] of course he got pushed
way too fast way too fast if he's coming
up right now they would treat him
different unfortunately usually one of
the last ones with UFC's like I just
throw him in the deep end see how it
goes now the UFC don't do that they
ruined Darren till they ruined him
they've ruined a lot of good Fighters
that way now they're they're learning
somebody's in the UFC office going no no
we got to take care of these young
prospects we're gonna do it like boxing
does we don't throw him to the [__]
Wolverines too early and unfortunately
he had this issue when he even at the
UFC they had this issue when you get to
one championship against Cosmo Alexander
so no one's really looking out for this
kid it's a shame talented [__]
bastard talented man dying piece looks
good speaks well sweetheart too right
guys you know
all right let's play a couple more have
you seen this video no what is it it
looks inside it looks like it's from
Russia and it's this dude that I don't
know he's just super tiny the other
guy's really really tall this is the
worst I don't know if it's called the
mullet it's like it's if you just listen
it's like Lloyd Christmas grew out of
mullet think of Lloyd Christmas top but
feels back
it's like dumb on the front party in the
back avoid Christmas yeah
his name was Lloyd Christmas
yeah the front's very Lloyd the back's
very Theo and the sides are very peanut
butter Falcon like it's just like he'd
cut it himself with a razor blade it's
like crying the ball it's everything
about you know what it is it's a
disaster it's a Russian disaster he's
lucky they don't shoot him on the
streets of Russia they don't play that
[__] out there man you get that weird
funky haircut they don't play that [__]
you're missing now who this weirdo that
he's fighting with I just from the video
against this guy's weird yeah they're
both what's going on here let me hit
play for me I wish I knew but I'll play
uh I don't know if there's okay no music
but I'll show them fighting right now
but the guy's so much smaller and just
destroys this guy
well he has some wrestling the tall like
meth Lloyd Christmas Russian this guy's
meth written all over him yeah he's
so bad
he's a chest tattoo
yeah he's getting destroyed by the
little he's so bad at fighting
he talked about the Bulldog choke and
his posture is so crazy yeah the whole
thing is just fantastic yeah
all right let's see if we can oh there's
a cool
up kick knockout here
oh out cold too
[Music]
it's always kind of the Hail Mary in MMA
I caught the Hail Mary like the chance
of that like you're never game planning
for that
and here's the last one
this is just a tease from Bigfoot Silva
hopefully it's not real
but then he goes he posts on Instagram
there's no human being on Earth alive
who could survive much agree Brogan said
to me I said who and their [__] right
mind which is going to take us you
better here's the thing like his chin is
dicey right so if one of those big
heavyweight slaps him first yeah you're
probably gonna win I don't know how they
decide who gets to slap first if whoever
in the [__] decides to let Bigfoot Silva
slap them with them giant banana hands
isn't gonna survive so as long as he can
slap first he'll be your world champion
multiple times over but as soon as they
can stop him back it's he's [__] what
else you got you that's pretty much it
for the current events all right kids we
already talked about the fights pretty
much but uh you got Bader Fedor on uh
baiter fader yeah baitor Bader I do the
same thing Fedor
um I think better is our second food
truck guest ever
second or third these are early early
Champion uh so you have Ryan Bader Fedor
uh for the heavyweight world title going
down on CBS Paramount plus this Saturday
you have Johnny eblin who's the
middleweight champion of Bellator top
five in any organization Neiman Gracie
Lorenz Larkin salt card
Brendan Ward Savage solid freaking card
uh they also got UFC Fight Night was
originally supposed to be Korean zombies
we have a bunch of cranes on their chins
celebrating already yep uh hopefully
Derek Lewis gets done there was a
picture of Derek Lewis looking in shape
but who knows could be in the camera
angle but he needs one he needs one's a
fork in the road so enjoy the fights
this Saturday I'll be watching The Green
Room I get uh to Springfield Missouri on
Friday morning so Friday two shows
Friday night two shows Saturday night
it's the Blue Room comedy club in
Springfield Missouri never been out
there I've been to Missouri I've been
Lake of the Ozarks never been to
Springfield so I'm looking forward to it
love new clubs new love new uh cities
stuff like that so Springfield I'll
probably be at your Bass Pro Giant Store
check out the fish out there so holler
at your boy if you see me but
Springfield is this Friday and Saturday
only February 3rd and 4th Naples is
February 16th through the 18th uh Naples
Florida at uh the off the hook Comedy
Club then Bakersfield California is one
night one show only February 23rd that's
almost sold out so get your tickets
right now Brea March 3rd there's no
Saturday now because the fight campaign
so it's just March 3rd so two shows in
Brea California that's a Friday March
3rd me and special guest that's Brea
March 3rd get your tickets now uh
fatkz.com or thickboy.com in Oklahoma
City March 9-11 they just had that
Oklahoma City Bricktown comedy club one
of my favorite clubs Oklahoma City March
9th 11th but uh Springfield Missouri
you're up this Friday and Saturday
looking forward to it uh check me out on
the companion next Saturday for the big
UFC Australia with Joe Rogan and friends
um we have dope food trucks dropping as
well uh so
well this Wednesday that's right this
Wednesday we have food truck coming in
hot Curtis blades our boy Curtis blades
he's training my team in uh Aurora
Colorado Cody Diamond shout out to high
altitude training and uh Curtis blades
food truck drops this freaking Wednesday
baby so that's a fun one all right kids
Springfield I'll see you this Friday and
Saturday be nice to each other stay safe
in the rain and everything else take
care thanks for tuning in like subscribe
love you guys see you next week if
you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding